voir des supporters qui est scandé le
nom des joueurs franchement ça fait
plaisir ayoub stade c'est
c'est plus chaleureux c'est combien
franchement ça fait du bien ça nous
avait manqué avec les petits problèmes
sanitaires du moment le plus heureux des
hommes retourner au stade un plaisir que
ses supporters n'avaient plus goûté
depuis de longs mois au menu des
retrouvailles ce 28 août le derby des
yvelines versailles poissy quatrième
journée de nationale 2 de football au
stade mont boron dans la cité royale au
coup d'envoi les deux équipes ont le
même nombre de points 7 au compteur et
le match est plutôt tendue versailles en
bleu se procurent les meilleures
occasions de la première période mais ne
trouve pas la faille à la pause toujours
0 0 on n'a peut-être pas
utiliser les failles qui avait par
exemple dans le dos de la défense mais
après on a quand même eu quelques
occasions il nous a manqué un peu
d'efficacité mais sinon s'arrêter au
retour des vestiaires c'est poissy qui
prend l'ascendant silva est déséquilibré
dans la surface pas de penalty pour l'
arbitre qui attribue même un carton
jaune pour simulation malgré les
protestations des visiteurs à la 70e
minute de jeu c'est une nouvelle fois
l'ailier pisciacais qui se distingue un
éclair de génie une frappe lointaine
enroulée du gauche qui ne laisse aucune
chance au gardien versaillais 1-0 pour
poissy
[Applaudissements]
dix minutes plus tard les pisciacais ne
sont pas loin de doubler la mise mais
laisse passer leur chance de l'autre
côté les versaillais y croit jusqu'au
bout on joue les arrêts de jeu
récupération du ballon à la limite de la
faute une dernière contre attaque tours
est parfaitement lancé vient remettre
les deux équipes à égalité score final
un but partout
l'axé jamais payé jusqu'au bout on a la
preuve aujourd'hui je me dis voilà la
plus grande frustration que depuis
savoir s'il ne s'est pas avoir
transformé toutes ces occasions de but
je pense qu'il y avait faute il y avait
morts il y avait des faits dieu qu'ils
ont fait que
on aura pu gagner le match mais
au final on repart avec un nul c'est
très frustrant on a eu le
je dirais le courage d'abnégation de
revenir au score dans les derniers
instants gucci voilà je pense que
la tournure du match aurait pu favoriser
poissy maintenant on a eu le mérite de
ne pas lâcher et d'y croire jusqu'au
bout et on a été récompensé au
classement du groupe a les deux clubs
zibeline auront donc tout de 8 points et
reste au contact du leader
saint-pryvé-saint-hilaire prochaine
journée le 4 septembre poissy reçoit
saint malo et versailles se déplace à
chartres